welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm really excited to
be joined by lauren langdale
who is currently the director of north
america at trust and soda
who are part of the trinovo group lauren
entered the recruitment industry in 2014
straight out of university
since then she's progressed all the way
from trainee to now director level
where she's responsible for leading a
team and the growth of the american
brand in trust and soda
along the way lauren has founded women
in devops which has grown to a worldwide
offline and online community of over 8
000 devops
engineers across the world the community
has become an
industry recognized not-for-profit
devoted to empowering diverse inclusion
within the technology space lauren
thanks for joining me on the podcast
thank you for having me amazing so
where i always like to start is in your
opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
probably one you haven't heard before
but integrity okay
and just having a huge amount of
integrity because
i think in today's landscape
it's so saturated that reputation is one
of the most important things that you
can have
and when clients and candidates
genuinely trust in you
and have faith in your ability to scale
teams for them
or to negotiate um packages
you know especially complicated ones i
think that's when your reputation your
networking
has like a dynamic change and does the
work for you
yeah i love that did you
have integrity from the beginning of
your recruitment career did you learn
that that's something that's actually
you
you have to have if you want long-term
success
um i i've always held myself
accountable to be like a very like
honest
person and
i think i believe i have i think what
changed for me
is probably in the last like three or
four years is that i've learned that
people want to work
with me for trust and so of course and
the brilliant brand you have but also
for me and kind of what that represents
when
there's a huge responsibility if you
think you're working like a startup for
example
and they're entrusting you to talk about
their baby or their next engineering
project with someone who might not have
heard of them before
if they have heard of them before not
know what they're doing from a technical
perspective but that's actually a huge
responsibility to get that right
and so i think that's something i've
learned
around you know just being myself
and actually being authentic people
recognize and can see
and me trying to be like overly salesy
or like
really trying to manipulate sales
process that just was just so unnatural
for me and
it just didn't work and i know that
works for some people but
but yeah not for me so i'd say in the
last year three four years
much better but um yeah something i've
learned
i like it i like it
so just for everyone listening for
context so we're going to really dig
into
your journey in taking your recruitment
career to america
for sure because i do feel like that
that
a lot of recruiters do inspire to do
that or at least open to it
and so we're going to talk about that
but let we're always like to just start
is like
what was lauren's first year recruitment
like what were the early days like what
was that first year like for you
straight out of university
oh my gosh yeah it seems like so long
going out which is um
it was quite embarrassing yeah my first
year so i started
um i took a recruitment job my
university town and i went to university
in cheltenham and i just i loved it i
absolutely loved being in the cotswolds
doing a [ __ ] revolution every friday
decided to go home i wasn't quite ready
to move to london
so i went for it our partners it was it
was fun it was good
um i did well they are a good
a good um group of lads i kind of like
learn the like traditional recruitment
methods you know like your lead cheats
and
yeah like that um but yeah i was with
them for about 18 months and then wanted
to relocate to london
and um yeah try something new okay
amazing so let's just talk about this
journey that you've been on then
with trust in soda so firstly also
you've had
ash on the podcast in the past and um as
well
so like when you joined what did the
business look like firstly
just to paint the picture for us so when
you joined because i feel like
over the last few years now that
tranovo's really built
a great brand right with the multiple
brands that they have so i guess what
did the business look like when you
joined
yeah completely different business
honestly um
i think i was employed like number six
or seven um
there's maybe like five or six of us in
a very
small office in holborn and we
said we shared an office with broadgate
search at the time i think maybe they
had like
six or seven as well so yeah very small
in its maturity but i could tell back
then and the reason why i joined was
that
it was really cool like the branding was
insane the message we already had like
in the same
client base that were working on like
shazam and people like that um from like
really early doors
um but yeah it was a lot of fun and
obviously that fun has continued but
um yeah it's obviously very very
different now and it's been an
interesting journey
having been with trust and soda five
years this may being like employee
number six
to then like launching like a whole new
office in a different continent um and
looking back and being on calls of like
50 60 people
yeah that's that's crazy right because
you you you hear
recruit recruitment businesses saying
this is where we're going and stuff like
that but to actually
go on that journey so i guess what what
i want to know from you then
is like firstly like i'm sure a lot of
recruiters listening to this
want to aspire to get to the position
that you are if that's director or
if that's to lead a team or even to take
their career to america so i guess
what i where i wanted to start was like
why do you think
lauren langdale was able to get the
opportunities that you've had
so let's just start with like why was
you the person
that made sure that when they thought
okay well we're thinking about going to
america
let's speak to lauren about that like
what did you do to make sure that
you're the person that got these
opportunities
for full transparency it wasn't actually
me that put my hand up to go to america
um it hadn't necessarily crossed my mind
um about relocating to the states i
always knew though that i wanted to get
to the top
of my game if that makes sense and i
yeah that there is no ceiling in chenovo
which is quite
a cool concept um the reason i think
that i landed the opportunity i did i'm
forever
grateful for probably is that like
integrity and authentic piece
um culture is really important to us and
me
and i think as you might have touched on
this actually when he spoke with you in
his podcast around
getting that culture right in a culture
that is is great but scalable and
and being able to replicate that in in
america was really important
um to the leadership team and something
that i guess they
they felt they had yeah
yeah i've built teams previously
demonstrated the billing
side um demonstrated
building a team of you know very
competent builders as well whilst
maintaining culture so i think that was
kind of the motivation behind that
decision okay
and then so you've spoken about culture
there i'm always interested to hear this
like so
in your opinion what do you think the
sort of free non-negotiables of the
trinovo group culture that you think has
been the sort of recipe of
success or cultivate the culture that
you're proud to be part of
yeah definitely um
so the thing is about chinovo is that
everyone
i want to make sure i communicate this
in the right way and it's okay
it's okay you know like the utmost
passion for what you do
and about carving out like a
hyper-performance
environment where
everyone has access to that performance
and where everyone feels valued no
matter what that performance
looks like um on top of
everything that we do around like
well-being and diversity and inclusion
and which i don't necessarily see is
like industry standard
um we invest a lot of time into making
sure
you know everyone's happiness is heard
and they're involved and
yeah it's a just a good place to be
where
if you want something we can make it
happen like i always tell the story
where
um myself and haley actually gone to
portugal for the weekend and we decided
that being in the office
at 8 30 a.m after 11 p.m flight back
from lisbon
um wasn't a great idea especially very a
presentation on the plane
but why would you have legacy time i
wrote the presentation on the plan of
why we should have flexi time
the the benefits of it and we walked in
to work on a monday we're like
hi ash dave can we have some time we
present this presentation
and they said um yeah you have a one
month trial
and if flexi time works and you can
prove that it's only going to
improve everyone's work life balance and
performance is gonna
go up then we can keep it if one
person's late on their flexi time
the deal scratch and it was great we did
it with a great month made a flexi time
you know policy for a few years before
introducing remote working so
i've not really been in very many
environments where that sort of um
proactive like attitude and yeah yeah my
hand up and have an idea and make it
happen kind of works i don't know that
obviously
no no no it does i think that i think we
yes like
i really like this sort of high
performance piece and having access to
that and
encouraging that and yeah like basically
what we're talking about there is that
yeah this culture has really high
standards and people do want to be
the best and wherever you are on that
journey we're going to support you
um but i think what you're sharing there
which i love is the
yeah i mean how i mean with the clients
you work with right how many clients say
that this is what they stand for but how
many people actually
live by that right so when you do have
an idea like that how many people go
yeah okay
great lauren even though one of our
values is innovative like no we don't
want to hear about that you know what i
mean so
i think that's a really cool story so
just so i think what what i'm really
keen to sort of dig into with you
is like this this joan that you've been
on in taking your career to america
um because as you shared with us before
we started this you actually moved over
there
yeah a couple of days before lockdown
and everything right so march last year
so so you shared about the they've
the people around you felt really
confident that lauren could bring over
is someone that could really live and
breathe this sort of trust and soda
brand and culture over to the states so
can we just talk a bit about
the sort of period where you spent in
the uk
building out that market so like where
where did you start
because there will be people listening
to this that may be thinking about
there's opportunities in america or
whatever but like where did you start
to build out this market yeah no of
course
um so we actually started six months
before we relocated
um for many reasons but i guess
main two ones were a to mitigate risk
right and and b or two sorry
um was to make sure
that we had the confidence from the day
we landed
so before we even set foot on a plane we
did six months working
west coast hours which were not fun but
you have to do it right
i was working to kind of two three four
am in the morning um
and then we did several business trips
just to have face time with those
clients and we had a women in devops
event
we hosted it at google um over here in
la
to start building our brand name so that
when we did land we weren't building
something from from scratch
and you know hemorrhaging money um
and time and resources it was a good
idea
it was hard don't get me wrong um
but we just learned so much in those six
months around
kind of what we wanted our market to
look like who our core clients were
going to be
finding um some core partnerships and
just little things like just really
understanding the local culture one of
the
biggest shocks for me i think was just
understanding
the cultural differences between a city
like london and los angeles and
when thinking about um jobs and career
paths and packages and how important
medical insurance is on 401k
and um you know salary boundings and
laws and compliance and risk is an
absolute minefield out here but
it meant that when we were going on
client meetings we weren't clueless
because we'd already been doing this for
six months
um got that so so basically you really
wanted to make sure that you had a
platform when you actually landed
uh yes so so what i want to know and i
know people
listen to this or want to know is like
so you mentioned there around
sort of understanding who you call
clients around stuff like that so i
guess
what i'm just interested to know is like
and this may seem like just
normal or basic to you but this is the
stuff that people like really want to
know because they can apply it right so
so you you
so you you're going to focus on the so
why did you pick la
why did you pick that state we picked
california
because well a california is the third
biggest economy on its own um
globally and
it is one of the biggest tech clubs in
the world and trusts and sodas
our core markets is digital and
technology um
san francisco obviously silicon valley
it's so expensive to be there um and los
angeles
has an incredibly strong
reputation when it comes to um the tech
space and it's growing incredibly
quickly
calling it like silicon beach now but
strategically located
in between san francisco great tech hub
and then also
san diego which is great for that
pharmaceutical med tech
and we wanted when thinking about like
our grand plan and our global strategy
and other locations like east coast is
very much on our radar like that'll be
the next step for us
just starting to kind of plot out those
global points
um plus you know the sunshine and
surfing before work
help any business case yeah yeah for
sure so
okay got that so thinking about the
bigger picture i guess so so identified
that and then i guess
like how did you go about then mapping
out the actual businesses you're going
to go after like did you go
to the existing clients relationships
you had and then started with
by finding out okay well what of our
existing clients have
functions in america let's start they're
like how how did you mark
how did you start market mapping and
where did yeah well how did you go about
that
yeah so it's at first it seemed like a
really like huge task but actually when
you
break it down and you create a plan and
a strategy um
it's not too dissimilar to what we were
doing back in the uk
so the first port of call was to of
course look at the
existing clients we had in our european
business and leverage relationships
of those um the second thing we did
would really utilize up within endeavors
platform
um so by setting up an event it was in
the no
it was in november 2019 and we didn't
move till march 2020 so
a good few months before we relocated
that gives us the opportunity to speak
to founders ctos engineering directors
invite them probe their brains um it was
the first event of its type
in los angeles so it was an incredible
opportunity for us just to have
honest conversations about diversity and
inclusion within tech in their
in the immediate arena in california
not only did we then get to build up
market knowledge we then got to speak to
candidates and potential clients about
non-recruitment topics which
in my experience is kind of when you can
build the most rapport sometimes
and really kind of get under the skin of
what of what um
they're looking to achieve without it
being too much of a sales call
and then the third thing was we invested
in job boards
um local job boards we use like a lot of
social media to resource our candidates
anyway so just make sure we're connected
with local groups
um and just kind of wanted to build our
our network um with very strong
candidates and clients
aligned with our markets in our sweet
spot which is like series a to series d
startups
okay got it so that that's really
helpful so
i'm definitely keen to dig into the
women in devops because the fact that
that's like one of your main
things that really helped you get
started here is amazing so
the first thing i just wanted to ask and
just dig a bit deeper on was
obviously it sounds really easy and
simple to go yeah we're going to speak
to our existing clients about america
but like how does that actual
conversation go for you to
get some traction you know what i mean
is it as simple as hey
such and such a personal relationship
with um i wanted to let you know that
we're actually expanding into america
it's actually
a really big part of our business plan
and i wanted to just
speak to you about who does whose
response for hiring over there or who
should i
speak to over there if we're heading
that way i don't know like how did that
conversation actually go and where did
you find you actually get the most
traction on that
yeah definitely i guess that also loops
back to that integrity piece as well
like it wasn't
um a difficult conversation for us to
have because we have such a strong
relationship with our clients and
actually
it was this is really exciting
off the back of our success with
you know folks like yourself and the
rest of our kind of journey in europe
we're actually launching
in the us we'd love to also support
teams out there and replicate the good
work we've done here
can you introduce me could we have a
meeting to discuss a usa strategy and
how
trust and soda can can you know scale
those teams across
across the atlantic um and
given the sort of relationships we had
you know that was that was fantastic and
we managed to kind of leverage off
our of our existing client pool not
everyone has offices in
in the us right yeah of course it's
simple to ask but
so obviously yeah it goes without saying
like this is the whole point of having
integrity doing the right thing
delivering like if you do that over a
long sustained period of time you build
relationships when
there is then a global expansion
opportunity you can then lean on those
people that
will give you the time will hopefully
help because you've delivered
right but i guess i'm just interested
because it makes sense to do that but
doesn't necessarily mean it's it works
do you know what i mean so
i'm i'm glad to hear that yeah so okay
so let's talk about women in devops then
with that being sort of
the number two thing that really helped
so so
look so you started that in what year
it was april 2017.
okay four years old why did you start
i started it because i wanted
a way two two reasons the first reason
is the genuine passion for
diversity equity and inclusion within
the tech space within
the market that i was hiring for and i
would
always attend a lot of meetups for three
reasons a to learn
and to be able to have tangible
conversation with hiring managers and
genuine screening calls and being able
to really kind of pick engineers brains
apart
to separate myself from the competition
the second reason is to meet
clients right and the third reason is to
meet candidates but
i felt like i was the majority of the
time not the only
kind of woman in the room and i didn't
really understand why because
i was placing a lot of um
female engineers and non-binary
engineers and transgender etc and
members of the lgbtq plus
community um the other reason
is i've built a lot
of my business plans and teams off the
back of innovation it's obviously a core
part of the turnover group and trust and
sodas values
but i wanted a way of connecting and
building a candidate pool that wasn't
off job boards or linkedin
um to create like those passive
relationships um
and also to give me like tangibility
when reaching out to candidates from a
diverse background that i really
genuinely cared and understood
what those conversations looked like
because when hiring
[Music]
a white male man everything
from that headhunt conversation through
to the interview through to the
negotiation
process through to the close is very
different
sorts of conversations i would have a
working mum for example
and i wanted to make sure that i had
credibility when having those
conversations
and that i would continue to be learning
and felt like i couldn't lean on the
community enough to learn so
i found my own one which is women in
devops in 2017.
yeah no i love that so there's a couple
of things here
that i'd really love you to share so one
is like what was the first step that you
took
so how how many i'm sure you've had it
in your time right how many
recruiters colleagues peers have gone
lauren i've got this great idea and then
nothing happens
right and this would have happened with
a lot of stuff like this the events and
stuff of that and
i think yeah so what was the like what
was it so from my dear you had that idea
like there's no one here that i can
relate to on i have more credibility
there's something i really care about
like what was the first step that you
took to actually make that reality
the first step that i took was
i secured budget for my directors
to run the first event so i secured
budget
i then started a meetup page
[Music]
decided on what i wanted the purpose of
the meetup to look like
and then to start inviting people um
i'm a big believer and if you say you're
going to do something do it
and when you again i know it seems like
i'm this is not really better
you literally call people and go hey
this is what i'm starting yeah
cool yeah i'd literally call or email
reach out linkedin
um i did a lot of work on twitter at the
time i still do use twitter a lot
um and just you know asking big
questions like hey how important
is diversity to your engineering team
this year
if it's not important well this is why
it should be
and i feel like this could be a really
good platform for you to learn network
on and if it is important
you should be here to meet to meet
others to meet
folks in the um in your you know devops
community
to talk and showcase like what you're
doing etc so
it's it's an easy but very important
cell um
if that makes sense yeah no it does so
the next thing that
i'd really like to share and i think
you're touching on it and when i ask you
why
you you've clearly really thought that
out understand it which i think is
really important stuff like this
like you've got the budget and stuff but
like like you said before you started
speaking to people about you really
thought about okay well
what is this about what do i want this
to stand for what's the purpose of it
um and i think it goes without saying
like this has got to be more than like
for me to so i can play some more
candidates yeah
yeah 100 like the
the thing is i guess this is a whole
there's a whole podcast in itself
around the fundamental importance of
having diverse tech teams
is we're literally building biased
algorithms
and biased products and
we're not going to understand the
effects too many years down the line i
actually watched a really cool
documentary
actually last night on netflix called
cody bias which kind of sums up a lot of
the work i've been doing for the last
three years
um was that cool sorry because i think
that'd be interesting coded by us
called coded bias on netflix um
i mean it is in the us so hopefully you
can watch it in in the uk but it
basically sums up
everything that i've been campaigning
for for the last kind of three or four
years so i like that this kind of
conversation is now becoming mainstream
and i think
that the layman or even if you don't
recruit in this area or care for
technology
i think people start to wake up um
so that that was really important to me
and
representing diverse candidates in the
space
and being able to build teams that
really reflect the world we live in
and be able to like differentiate i
cannot say that
did we enter you know what i'm
interested in we know what you're saying
yeah um between my competitors but
um yeah it all just kind of stems down
to that like true kind of passion and
integrity for
for really wanting to build and scale
diversity teams globally
so so my next point on this and i feel
like you've touched on it so if there's
not much to add just let me know but i
guess
like where so okay so we thought about
the idea of taking the first few steps
but i'm now worried about getting people
bought in to
getting involved i think not everyone's
going to start a meetup series around
diversity inclusion i think that that's
really compelling and i think
most people would want to try and at
least i'd like to think understand
contribute or whatever but i guess where
sometimes people then fall short is
on on like clients or candidates just
going to think i'm a recruiter trying to
get people in the room so i can make
money out of them to go i mean so i
guess
how how did you make sure that i don't
know how do you get people brought in so
it seems like you really led with like
the purpose behind it and stuff but like
how did you get
people yeah on the bus and bought into
what you were trying to do
yeah definitely i think even even that
circles back down to that integrity
piece
yeah yeah you're right it and being it's
a genuine movement which
genuinely is advocating for
underrepresented groups within
technology
who are you know constantly looking to
showcase
the voices of intersectional diversity
with globally um and if you're being
genuine and and having that integrity
piece
people don't look at you like that you
know they can see what you're doing you
have the track record
um it took time to scale don't get me
wrong at the first few meetups
um we maybe only had
[Music]
like 20 to 40 and now we're kind of
averaging between like one
150 to 200. um
but also just understanding and having a
plan and being able to communicate
to anyone that's interested okay well
this is where we are now this is our
roadmap
these are our success points and this is
what we're achieving
and being able to communicate that quite
clearly opposed to just being like oh
well um we have these drinks on a
thursday
and yeah i go you mean yeah yeah i'll
get that
okay amazing so we're definitely i'm i'm
gonna
we'll dig into it now but before we do i
really want to
want to speak about the dna piece um and
we have been but
like the final piece to tie this all
together is back to the point on like
how
like you wouldn't have continued to do
this i personally i think
feel free to disagree with me but i
think it's amazing what you stand for
but
there definitely is commercial benefits
to this from a recruiter's
point of view yeah so like for me i
guess what would be really good for
important to hear is not
we've just spoken most the time around
the purpose how it can help people et
cetera et cetera
but like let's just break this down
really simple for people like how has
this helped you
grow your recruitment desk like we don't
need to talk about how much money it's
made you buy let's just talk about
how has it actually impacted your
recruitment deaths what have been some
of the biggest wins that you've had
and stuff like that because i think
that's what recruiters need to hear that
yeah this is yeah um
this from a commercial sense this works
um to put this into perspective woman in
devops in
2020 was the fourth highest
source of revenue wow
interesting soda that's big
yeah it was it came higher than any job
board we've invested in
everything the only thing that beat it
was linkedin in different parts
and such so if that doesn't tell you how
commercially viable
you know investing like that purpose
time
and planning i don't i don't know what
will and we had a great year last year
we
had a record-breaking year last year so
it was yeah
i love that okay amazing thank you for
sharing that so
so let's look could we because we've
ended up going here let's talk about the
dna piece right because i'm sure you can
agree like you've mentioned it already
i think so the conversations that i've
had with recruiters i
personally i feel like most recruiters
are genuinely curious maybe even
passionate
and under wanting to understand like how
they can
i don't know like play a part right
because i think
as as we all well hopefully if you
listen to this you you really hold what
you do into account and that's what you
learn from integrity like really taking
what you do seriously
as a recruiter and i think yeah i think
most clients and businesses
this should be in their top three things
they will be thinking about i i feel
like from everything that
i'm taking in and the sort of lens that
i'm viewing the world
through but i guess like what i'm trying
to what i'm trying to ask you is like
there'll be a lot of people listening to
this that generally
have the right intentions that are
curious about it for the right reasons
do want to know
more about about the right reason do
want to help their clients for the right
reasons
but they have no idea where to start
like
yeah so like where where can people
start like it seems like
where you started was you really got
curious about it and you wanted to
connect people to get educated about it
but i guess for people listening
that do share that same intention the
right intention that you've spoken about
that integrity like where do we start to
learn about this
so we can start going on this journey
yeah definitely my actually the
the most the first thing that jumps to
my mind is to speak to your candidates
and clients so
here in california in particular and i
had this in the uk as well but more so
in the us
market is when you're speaking to hiring
managers
19 you know the majority of hiring
managers now
have some sort of
um driver towards building a diverse
team and that's like at the forefront of
their targets right so you need to be in
as their recruitment partner to be
competitive
and you need to be a true a true like
extinction to their business you also
need to be in line with their thinking
is utilize your immediate network like
just ask questions
and there is a ton of resources out
there there are
podcasts on spotify there are blogs our
instagram accounts
there are books there's the netflix
documentary that i um
i i mentioned earlier
but you sometimes you have to have
difficult conversations and that's okay
and that was a big thing that came out
of the the black lives matter movement
last year in the us
is like have difficult conversations and
educate yourself and it's okay like
to to learn and to like
not necessarily understand if that makes
sense but just make sure you're
educating yourself i don't want to
become i don't want to look a preaching
podcast but
there is so many resources out there but
maybe start with your horror matches
like starting for clients like what are
your clients doing around dee and i
what can you do more like what are they
not seeing from you
you're not sending a diverse shortlist
why are you not sending a diverse
shortlist
is it worth doing like some unconscious
bias training
yourself when looking at resumes um
and also just understanding that if
you're
just using the bog standing recruitment
tools you're probably gonna
have an undiverse shortlist in the first
place right um
so just also my advice would be like
learn different ways about
resourcing
diverse candidates i think it's not
making any sense but
no i've got it so yeah
i think where it all starts i love that
you said that because i think there is
that there is that worry isn't there
whereas like
oh am i gonna say something wrong or am
i gonna offend people and that can
really just stop people from taking any
sort of action
um and also i think i'll speak for
myself but like being
a white male to like try and have
conversations about
these topics sometimes you can just feel
like am i the am i
like who am i to like even talk about
this you get what i'm in
um so i think what i love about that
which hopefully people can take away is
like
start like if i think you like you said
like if you're not you need to be at
least having the conversations
like and it's okay if you you're not
gonna be
an expert you're not like that's okay
but it's like
you need to be a recruiter that is
willing to at least answer questions and
actually to start these conversations
because
then you're you're seen as someone
that's willing to have those
conversations
and you're not going to be yeah put
aside or left out if there's recruiters
that they're working with that aren't
actually having those conversations you
know what i mean so i think it all
starts with
being curious yeah there's so much
information we can self-educate
ourselves on
and and start asking those questions
that yeah may maybe feel
make you feel a bit oh should i be
asking that but i think
that's where it all starts exactly and
like just to be clear
as well like this all loops back to
being
an incredibly high bear and
everything that we're talking about now
puts you into those next bracket right
and creates it creates employee
engagement it drives right behavior
and ultimately separates you from every
other like recruiter
out there and yeah i feel like in in
today's
market these are some these are sort of
conversations that
are going to make you more money and
you're going to be a better off the back
of it um
because you can drive that engagement
with the clients and have those more
difficult conversations and just really
understand what's important
cool right i really enjoyed going
through that with you that was awesome
no that was good so so obviously we
spoke about
six months building the platform
obviously we spoke about woodland devops
because that was the number two
thing that you really leveraged to
obviously start building a brand over
there and stuff like that
so um like we i feel like we've been
really positive right so
people want to know the dark days like
the tough days and recruitment right so
could you
i don't know what comes up for you when
i say to you okay lauren well what
like where were like the really
challenging points and experiences that
you had to work through when
going through this transition and
journey and building out this american
business from scratch like i don't know
what were some of the real biggest
challenges and hurdles that you had to
overcome
the the real dark days
um was building a business from scratch
in a brand new continent and landing
four days before
a national state lockdown during a
pandemic that was about to last 12
months
not knowing um what was going to happen
that that was tough that was really
really tough we had a plan
you know we were prepared we'd we'd
mapped out our strategy
but i'm guessing like everyone else in
this industry
hadn't mapped out what we were going to
do
did at least you go in the bin basically
a little bit yeah
yeah i mean we still have the structure
right and we came out the other star
side we still had an incredibly
successful
year um and generated
revenue and and yeah bought a new
clients and
and that was it was fine but you we
immediately had to pivot
in regards to how we were embracing um
recruitment and how we were going to do
things differently
and how we're going to scale i guess
like everything
everything that i've done in the last 24
months the question
at the end of every plan is like will
this scale can this scale
um so it was trying to
make sure that everything we were still
doing was scalable during a pandemic
because it was part of this bigger
picture we didn't want to just still be
like a
you know a two-man team um
in 12 months time so they were the dark
days they're just having to pivot having
to be agile having to think in your feet
make quick decisions
um and just back yourself and i've
definitely struggled with confidence in
the past
yeah oh that was a tough time for me
well what what because i think like we
can talk about it now can't we but like
i mean it's so easy to forget like how
you would have felt and how he would
have been thinking in those periods you
know what i mean
but like i don't know what helped you
get through that period because like
yeah you've come out the other side
there's great things that you can talk
about but i guess what
because i think people can relate to
this not just because of the last year
but
we all have those low days in
recruitment don't we we all have
those really difficult times we've got
to push through i guess what were your
sort of anchor points or what
did you sort of draw on to be like no
this is why i'm here this is why i'm
doing that
that helps you sort of see some of the
light at the end of the tunnel
um drinking a lot of red wine
that's fair
i drank a lot of wine in 2020
honestly just sticking to your vision
and that's something i think we've
we've really nailed trust and soda is
like having that vision
believing in it saying we're gonna do it
and do it
and it didn't matter kind of what went
wrong
or what fell through or
we just kept that vision at the
forefront of everything we were doing
and did not let us deviate which
is we have a two and a half and a five
year plan basically is the the immediate
vision
where where do you want to be q4 2022
what that looked like from
a revenue perspective head count
perspective you know additional offices
in the us
and um i just kind of kept that there
that you like draw a chart and put it on
my
what my bedroom walks obviously wasn't
going to the office um
i had the numbers highlighted and it was
just a case of
we will get there we've just got to take
take the long route we just have to take
a couple of um
you know alleyways and yeah just just
the
i cannot stress the importance of having
a vision yeah absolutely
i think that's that's the common thing i
think it's if you haven't taken the time
take a step back and think about why
you're doing it or
where you're going then yeah you can't
then take that
step back can you and you're just then
focused on the challenges that you face
that day
rather than like that will only be one
day out of
300 days on the way to where you want to
get to do you know what i mean so
yeah okay exactly
i think it's so easy to be bogged down
especially
in the pandemic you know deals fell
through because people lost
budget and you know people didn't turn
up to interviews because they were had
child care that day and
all those little things it's so easy to
build on that but when you're just so
crystal clear okay well that's what i
need to achieve this is such a small
piece of the journey and puzzle
all of a sudden it kind of like took the
stress away not at all
but like i know what you mean yeah
connective live perspective yeah
so important okay so before we finish
then
let's get into some some details which i
think people would really
enjoy and want to know so like
people want to know like can you
actually like
make more money in america like what are
let's tell us a bit about the typical
sort of um
of percentages that you'd agree with
clients talk to us about
average deal size compared to because
you was doing the same market in the uk
but now in america right so just give us
some like real life context on that in
your world because i think people want
to know that
yeah i cannot stress enough
how exciting the u.s recruitment market
is
and the real opportu the real
opportunity
to make incredible profit here
um there's i think ashley might mention
this my
um found on his podcast with you
actually but there's something
ridiculous that there's 26 000 less
recruitment companies in the us and
there is in the uk
that's mental and then if you just think
about the sheer scale
and population contrast between the uk
and the us
it's almost like why wouldn't you do the
us market um but on top of that the
commercial the commercial
just makes commercial sense um to focus
and invest in the us so
my average margin in in the uk was was
sat around at the 18
mark um in regards to when you say
margin sorry
just says in the average what
do you mean sorry like the
which would add up in the uk and then
you add the perspective
of so my core market is devops
and you know a good senior devops
engineer in london we're down you know
somewhere between kind of 75
to 85 90 mark in the us or in particular
in california
we're looking at like 175 to 200k
um all of a sudden and you're looking at
you know 35 to 40
what was your average deal size last
year our average deal size last year was
30 grand
dollars yes that's and it's like i know
there's nuances and
stuff like that i know but people want
to know this but like it is
as a as a whole just we're going to
paint like just a general brush of this
it's the same skill set
it's exactly the same skill set
you just have to learn about like
compliance and
you know all those elements which you
need to learn in the uk in the first
place there's no difference gdpr in an
r35 but
if we're talking about the skill set of
just
if we really break it down right or
picking up jobs and placing candidates
there is no difference across the
atlantic
except we are looking at incredibly high
fees
yeah yeah yeah yeah and
more of it you know it's less saturated
yeah
okay i'm glad you shared that so what
what i want to
know as well then is like so over the
last so what did you what did you end up
doing
billings wise for you personally in that
sort of first whole year
actually being in america does that work
out with your year to year or
what was the first personally
i built about i think it was 720 last
year
wow yeah
i mean i did that does include some kind
of some some contract stuff but
and yeah it was it was a good a good
year as a team we want to do
more closer to 2.6 million this year and
bearing in mind you know we only landed
on the on the ground last march and
it's been a pandemic hopefully that
gives you an idea of the sort of
scale that is really realistic
if you work hard and have a business
plan a really clear vision
yeah because i i just want to know them
before we finish this because i think
it's really important just to because i
think this is a big
reason why i started this is to actually
just give like the actual realities
because
we can hear those big numbers and go oh
yeah like i'm sure it's been
easy like you're doing the same job in
uk but you're getting paid more for it
right but i know that's
far from the truth so like i guess one
the first thing first part is
how long would you say that it it really
took you to build traction
um to get to the point where you had
sort of monthly opportunities to to
make a good amount of placements like
how long did it take obviously you
started six months in the uk
build a platform and then went on the
ground but then covered it but like
what how long of the time would you say
it it took to get traction for people to
know
um six months would be my number and
when thinking about hiring my team and
scaling my team like six
six months from a from a standing start
standard start yeah
nice so the next thing that i wanna know
is then like
what has been and again you may end up
saying women devops but i want this
i want you to share this so like what
has been like the most effective way
for you to get traction on the client
side over the last
18 months um women in devops has
definitely been one of them
especially in california where
diversity is really at the forefront um
and i'll also say that your referrals
and networks like
the thing the thing is about the us is
you also you have some of the best
brands in the world here
right it's just mad what's on your
doorstep especially here in california
and i know there's other locations like
austin and
new york when thinking about um
technology in particular but
once you start building your network and
get recommendations like it's just like
wildfire and
it's such a huge piece of land but it's
also such a small world
um you do a good job for good people
they're going to tell people about it
and
you're going to have retainers on before
you know hr even know about it
but women and devils of course has been
a a great way for us because it's
a passive and unique candidate pool
that just no one else has and i cannot
stress enough about thinking about
kind of your market and how you can
build something similar
um and the third thing is just absolute
sheer persistence and resilience
and just every day just turning up
and and working for lack of a better
expression in your ass off
yeah yeah so love that so like what
what i want to know then before we
finish so people love this stuff as well
lauren i'm just asking what people want
to know okay she just mentioned there so
i think you wrote that down really well
but people want to know so you said
they're around showing up every day
doing we need to do
so like people want to know how you've
remained productive
how you've sort of max what you've done
to maximize
most your day's weeks right so people
always ask me like
what does a typical day for lauren like
how do you structure a day do you do two
hours of bd always in the morning like i
don't know like people just want to
people want to know this stuff
right yeah so like i guess how have you
over the years and what do you do what
are your non-negotiables now but like
how do you structure your day
to give yourself the best chance of
performing every day
yeah definitely so there's definitely
some like deviations in this but to give
you a bit of like a rough
idea um so
first thing set my team up for the day
you know we have like big goals mini
goals for across the quarter of the day
in the morning
um and that could be anything in regards
to
leads you know resume sent oh gosh i'm
really american now
to you know client calls but then also
it could be anything
from you know linkedin content
and you know how many comments or likes
we aiming to get here like how are we
engaging our community today what do i
post like
setting up the team and just kind of
getting them on board and just
reinvested every single day and exactly
what it is we're trying to achieve like
um on a daily basis and then
um i tend to
work on candidate stuff in the morning
i'm such a foodie and like food just
gives me life so
it makes sense do a client work in the
afternoon um
but i always finish the day with and
actually something you taught me around
like
content and embedding myself into the
social media
of my market and and taking that
opportunity to learn
um i then kind of break my dab a little
bit differently i kind of try to finish
it like an okay time
head home go for a walk i don't know
whatever and then i jump back on my
laptop
um and then really use those like a few
hours to get my admin done like
i just feel like your days are so
important
that i don't want to be sat doing admin
in the middle of the day that is my
opportunity to speak to candidates to
speak to clients to get on the phone
um and then i kind of do my admin like
back end of the day on the sofa
usually glass of red wine as we've
established on this podcast
and make sure that's up to speed because
actually it's a parting like piece of
advice
i was really poor at admin for the first
four years of my career
and i kick myself every day for not
being better
because i now understand the importance
of the database
and what it can generate for you and
when thinking about your future self
like just make sure your stuff is on on
whatever system and you're recording at
your recording notes because your memory
is not as good as you think it is
and um the last two years i started to
really take data seriously and make
data-driven decisions and it is
changed it has changed the game for me
yeah so when you say admin just to be
clear you're talking about
making sure that yeah the database is up
to scrap
up to date all of that yeah even if the
candidates aren't right if your roles
like get them on there like
code up tag it we use bullhorn as our
crm so i know
you know when he's a different stuff but
um and just having like accurate notes
um i was also so blase for so many years
and
um like i really kick myself because
when thinking about your future self and
if you want to be a manager your future
team
that is a gold mine for the next kind of
like yeah yeah
your life i think that's a great way to
pull it is like
when you when you're if you're listening
to this and you're thinking after that
call
i can't wait to put those nights on
whatever it's like right i need to think
of my future self like i think that's
such a good way to put it
yeah i mean um okay so we always end
with like five final questions
okay i've got like two just really
simple ones before
so as we're talking about stretching the
day and stuff like that i always love
asking this question so
what do you think is the most important
action or kpi kpi that contributes
to recruiting success the most important
one
the most important kpi yeah
i would say your your resume or your cv
sent to first interview ratio nice
i like that that's a good one few people
said that and quite a few people have
said
number of meaningful conversations every
day but yeah i think i really like that
one that's a good idea
for conversations but i feel like
meaningful like how is that
how tangible is that yeah yeah i know
i like a bit of tangibility in my life
um
you can't measure quality of a
meaningful conversation because like
what's the action point
yeah to see yeah i like that cool so the
other question is i know
yeah so you're as you've shared like you
have a vision on these things so i guess
like what how do you view this sort of
u.s
market recruitment market over the next
sort of year or two like
are is it because i think before covid i
think
so many recruitment businesses i spoke
to like it was all about the us
and i think some companies have still
sort of continued to make that happen
but i guess if i'm listening to this
right now like how realistic is it for
me
as a uk based recruiter may have
experience got a good track record of
like taking my career to the states
like is that still attainable over the
next 12
24 months and do you think that's
something i should be thinking about
why are you still thinking about it just
do it
no no like honestly definitely um
we we've got huge scale plans to scale
across um
boston midwest midwest offices
um we're just pumping more gas rather
than taking off
on the off the pedal now we're also
expanding globally and looking at
switzerland and dark and stuff like that
and they're also being super successful
but
um for me my focus is obviously the us
and it's where
a lot of our investment and time and
resources is going
so i guess why i asked that was like
would do you think it's going to be more
difficult for me to get a visa let's say
or do you i don't know any sort of
things like that that you've been
thinking about or know about just out of
interest
um i'm not an immigration attorney so i
don't necessarily want to make him like
sweeping state yeah of course
um i think with the new u.s
administration
and the new government that i think
that's going to change kind of the
narrative
of of what um visas look like and i'm
really quietly confident that when the
board is open i'm
i'm certainly really excited to look at
like internal and external talent
from the uk um and i'm hoping would be a
fairly seamless
transition for full transparency getting
my own personal visa
was the most underwhelming process i've
ever been through
like underwhelming like difficult
nice and i thought it'd be really hard
honestly i was so nervous about my visa
appointment they just asked what my
degree was and then just like stab my
passport and that was that i was like
right okay
um but look as long as you've got good
leadership
and good attorneys i really do not
foresee
problems because what these are you on
just on that because i think that's
interesting
yeah i'm on an e2 so the big ones if if
you're in the uk
um is the e2 or the l1 visa so your l1
is like your internal business
transfer and then who is the investor
visa so for us
it make commercial sense down the e2
route and we can just add
people to our e2 visa um it's a fair
it's a fairly simple process
okay nice yeah and i know that that goes
about the disclaimer that lauren isn't a
immigration attorney
how realistic is it and stuff okay yeah
all right yeah i don't i feel i feel
like that could put people like people
off do i mean being like
all this stuff yeah yeah really it's
just a few forms you fill in on an
interview
and there's there's lots that you can do
to control it i'd like to think like if
you're again
general statement but if you're in a
company that is taking america
seriously i'd like to think they'd
invest in the right law help and stuff
like that so
i think people will be able to tell you
yeah lauren look with your background or
whatever you have because you don't have
this i'm not sure how realistic you know
what i mean i'd like to think that
they'd be able to find that quite
quickly wouldn't they yeah you can
turn up to the embassy and they say
sometimes you know it's not as
straightforward as that and you still
want to go through the embassy interview
but i would just hate for that
process to put anyone off from another
favorite adventure
yeah absolutely right so i've got a last
couple of questions for you okay
we'll finish this up so first one is um
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
or i would improve
i don't like bias because when i came
into industry it was cool times and lead
sheets but
that just mentality of like that's how
you measure success
within trainees and junior consultants i
really hate that mentality
nice so what book have you read and that
could be either
audio i don't know just something that
you've taken in
that's had the biggest impact on you
could be something you watched um it's
actually a book
that underpinned a big presentation i
did in brazil a few years ago
around recruitment it is called
technically wrong
by technically wrong nice
yeah it's it's called technically wrong
by
sir
[Music]
someone maybe you could put the link to
it and yeah i will i'll put the link to
it
sarah watcher voucher i'm really sorry
not that sarah will be listening but um
technically wrong
okay cool yeah and and basically that
kind of underpins
the mindset change of um how important
diversity was and how i was basically
going to
build a recruitment strategy with de ni
the focus of it
i love that it's a bit of a different
and fun one here
yes what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on i
went to dubai for the dubai sevens my
big rugby fans so i went out to dubai
every penny of it
it was but yeah awesome
final question what's what's the
ultimate goal for your recruitment
career
um the ultimate goal for me is to
be um
leading and growing the u.s for chinovo
group
with multiple different brands
underneath me multiple different offices
and having
the highest performing office within
geneva i'm i'm here for a long time like
i'm really sold like i
yeah geneva is it for me and um had a
great journey so far and there's so much
this time still so much more to achieve
so
yeah taking america love it
lauren it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for having me
thank you